i saw on your on your page like for i
think it was like day 19 there was a
girl and there were two black eyes yeah
so she got those black eyes like
fighting another girl on the show um
okay so look this is how it works i
insist on them to box so if two girls
have an issue
we do our best to
not let them get close to each other and
fight
um but we're not watching them 24 hours
you know every minute of the day so
sometimes they might get into a quick
little
right
that could be an accidental win you know
that could be an accidental i just got
the best of you that you know at that
time
so
we break it up and i insist on them to
box because we're not gonna break it up
and you can go as far as you want with
the gloves on you know so that's the
real entertainment part of it that
you have these girls signing waivers
right so you protect yourself
waivers i just want to make sure you're
good a waiver god forbid one of these
[ __ ] gets knocked out and hits their
head on the counter or something on the
show and then you're liable
they signed more than a waiver um